in this morning's eye on earth a
stunning new report shows many major
coastal cities around the world could be
underwater by 2050 in our lifetime
scientists from Climate Central say that
means 300 million people would be
waterlogged in just 30 years take a look
at these images here are the original
predictions for 2050 and then these are
the climate Central's new projections
take a look at the dramatic impact in
places like Bangkok Thailand Alexandria
Egypt and closer to home coastal
Louisiana it shows each area almost
completely underwater bernadette woods
plakias chief meteorologist at climate
central and she joins us now for
enternet good morning joining the
original projections were already
frightening now we have these new
projections even more concerning first
question why the change well first of
all thank you for having here to talk
about this very important subject and
this is a nice piece of the puzzle and
understanding more about how climate
change is really affecting the people
places and things that we love what we
did with this study is we looked at land
beneath our feet
sea level rise projections in the past
were based on this wonderful global data
set from NASA but what it did was read
our land as a satellite went around the
earth and what that land was reading was
trees buildings and the land that was
way above where we actually walk when we
were able to correct this elevation data
set it brought land closer to where we
live so when you have that same amount
of water and land went from here to here
yeah a lot more terrific what are the
most vulnerable areas here in the u.s.
in the United States actually our data
set has not changed that much because we
have a really robust wonderful
scientific system and we use what's
called lidar data so it's a little more
refined so we already know major areas
at risk as we showed Louisiana Florida
all of the entire southeast coast and
even it's all just this past month with
king tides water coming up with no storm
system from Virginia New Jersey all the
way up into Boston but the reason this
matters to Americans even if the
flooding is happening somewhere else is
because if people are displaced that
creates conflicts aggregates wars for
resource
US military involvement could follow
instability is bad for global security
and for security here at home I noticed
that Asia seems to be a particularly
hard hit why well one of the reasons it
is so highly populated and there's a lot
of low level ground and with population
levels so high and not much protection
there
you're already are seeing those are some
of the places already at risk but then
when you correct to this data set it
just raises those numbers off the charts
so now that you've scared the bejesus
out of us can you explain simply and
what why is it happening and what we can
do so my goal is not to scare you it's
to form you everybody this is what we're
looking at if we don't make changes but
we do still have the opportunity to make
changes I can compare it to a diet you
know even if you choose to eat healthy
it's gonna take a while to see those
impacts on your body yes our greenhouse
gases stay in the atmosphere for
hundreds to thousands of years and
that's why there's an urgency to change
to cleaner sources of energy electrify
our transport make for refined ways of
working our buildings our heating
systems our lighting systems and focus
on our farming and our agriculture where
we have some opportunities with our
soils I can't personally redefine our
electricity system but I think what
you're saying is people can vote for
people who do right it's one of the ways
I thought it's funny when I said doesn't
drive you crazy when people still don't
understand climate change you go yeah
like my dad even in your own house
all right Bernadette with Blackie thank
you very much we appreciate it